well i'm joined here in wembley by our
sports editor nick powell so nick the
team sheets in what do you make of it
well it's a big surprise i don't think
many people saw the one
change that gary southgate has made
which
changes the shape of the team it goes
back to the shape that he had against
germany to counteract
the german system the germans played
with three men at the back and then two
wings back
wing backs who are right back and left
back defenders if you like when you're
defending but their job is to get up and
down the flanks
uh and match up what the germans know
that's this is not matching up what
italy do
uh and my reading of it is uh is twofold
uh or even three for one he wants to
keep it fairly tight so he's got five
people who are essentially defenders
above all
so he keeps it tight tries to keep it
scoreless maybe
for the first hour or so and then bring
on his jack relishes his exciting young
players because the man who drops out
of the starting level in that one change
uh also he'd be concerned about the
threat that
italy do have going down the fence
they've got two very good uh wide menu
could be a threat for england so you try
and counteract
that and also he likes the spring of
surprise uh garrosh there's almost
always a surprise this is the first time
that he's kept the same team had he done
so
since the last big match the semi-final
at the world cup in 2018 but once again
one change he likes to keep us guessing
of course he wants to keep the italians
guessing
as well because the italians would not
have seen this coming they'd they'd have
prepared for it
but it would be in the back of their
minds not the front of their minds and
in terms of what's happening now in the
stadium they're behind us they're here
the
the italians have arrived i think um
gareth gets a huge amount to protect the
team to keep them in this bubble to keep
them focused on the task in hand just
winning the matches
not listening to the noise outside as it
were
but you know here wembley is humming the
excitement
you know it's palpable in the air how
how are the team going to be feeling now
do you think because it's
you can only be inspired by that i was
talking to david seaman an hour or two
ago
uh broadcasting on sky sports news and
he was playing
at the old wembley for england at uh
euro 1996 where
uh england got the semi-finals and lost
on penalties to germany he played at
world cup's david seaman
as well and he was saying you just soak
up the atmosphere you
you use it in your own way that they're
too experienced to be thrown by that but
you're right
gary said has kept them in their bubble
as far as you
can both from a mental point of view of
what you meant but also today
from a safety point of view because i
think they would have quite liked to had
a walk about in normal times
and interact a little bit with the fans
at least let the fans see them they
didn't do that they
did have a walk about at the the team
base in staffordshire and george's park
the fa headquarters these days
but it was on a very big complex it was
way out of
out of reaching out of sight of the fans
they would like to have connected with
the public because southgate has been
brilliant
at understanding the connection with the
public and it's really telling
that was it 36 37 seconds that the
gareth southgate
delivered to camera today which you
played just now one of the things he
said was
i hope we've represented the country in
the right way not too many england
managers would have got that into their
37 seconds before the biggest match of
their lives